well many of us depend on technology to
thrive in today's world and while local
organizations say some progress has been
made with more women in the field we
really need to do better to empower
women of color sally jaramillo spoke to
some who are working hard to bring that
change
i walk into a room where
there is just me or
a handful of people who look like me
franisha latrice hayes works at kmj web
to sign a house web design company and
says times are changing women are
starting to flood the tech industry
we are
rare when it comes to minority women for
me technology is
a field that is never going away brionda
barrett is a recruiting coordinator at
taurean consulting group and says as
technology increases in our day-to-day
activities and workplace it's important
we bring diversity to the tech field the
statistics show that 26 of women um are
in in the i.t field only about three
percent of women who are
african-american are in i.t and only two
percent of latino hispanic women are in
the i.t field no matter where you are in
your professional development or what
technology-related field you're in
experts say there are multiple
opportunities for women in the valley we
do as we go out into the community
programs like i.t works and so we go in
there and become mentors eli shiva
anderson is the research and planning
manager for global social foundation a
technology-based foundation that offers
technological services to programs that
may not have proper funding we give them
training on technology provide them with
cell phones provide them with
information on how to use technology
their first project data soko which
allows women to sell their own products
we feed the women we feed the entire
community salihara live local now